[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cheers.
To friendship.
-Yeah.
-It's always good to see you,
Ryan.
And you're just so cool, man.
-You too.
-I can't believe you've played
two superheroes
over the course of your career.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, it's crazy.
Yeah, I played --
First, I played Deadpool.
You know, that was in the
"X-Men" movie that --
nobody liked that. [ Laughs ]
Then I played Green Lantern
in a -- in a DC movie,
which nobody liked.
-Yeah.
-And then I played --
I played, like, the --
the new Deadpool,
which, you know, people --
people actually really liked.
-Yeah. I respect that
about you.
You're willing to own all the
bad movies you've been in.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Thank you.
You know what I respect
about you?
You knew when to give up making
movies entirely.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a nice thing to say.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I respect
about you?
You named your movie,
"Free Guy,"
because you knew no one
would pay to watch it.
-I know.
-I love it. I respect that.
-You're, like, your --
-I respect that.
-You're too kind, Jimmy.
You know what I respect
about you?
-What's that?
-You don't let the deadness
in your eyes stop the laughter
in your heart.
-Wow.
-Not at all.
You know what I respect
about you?
-Hmm?
-You fight against offensive
stereotypes,
like Canadians being likable.
-Hmm.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Well, you know,
something I really,
really respect about you
is that you know the phrase,
"Dance like no one is watching?"
-Yeah.
-Well, you do everything
like no one is watching.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I respect
about you?
You talked about being named
"People's" sexiest man alive
in 2010, and you never
considered just how long ago
that actually was.
And that -- You don't have
to do that, but you --
-Yeah.
-It's interesting.
I respect --
-You know what I respect about
you -- I mean,
really respect about you?
Is you've never given up on
trying to make facial hair work.
So, I think that's --
-Well, I respect --
I respect you
for respecting that.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know?
-Yeah.
-♪ R-E-S-P-E-C-T ♪
-♪ Find out what it means
to me ♪
-Together: Sock it to me,
sock it to me.
Sock it to me.
Sock it --
[ Punch sound effect ]
[ Laughter ]
-For the mess.
[ Cheers and applause ]